[Music]
hello guys today we're going to talk
about motivation so to understand
motivation could be like a challenge so
to understand motivation requires living
into the complex interplay of psychology
so social and
interal factors that drive human
behavior as a fundamental force that
PS propels in rols to act in pursuit of
special goals motivation has long been a
subject of eiz research and debate
within the REM uh real remains of
psychology sociology and organization
Behavior by examining the
multif nature of motivation one can gain
insight into uh it into various forms
underlying Mech uh mechanisms and uh
implying uh across a different Dominics
of of human life uh motivation one
prominent the is a MOS higher C of needs
which uh postulate that IND the worlds
are motivated by a progression of need
uh ranging from basic psychology reir to
higher
level this uh framer work HL the higher
Social nature of motivation
ation uh imping the Demonic interplay
between fundamental human needs and uh
the and the priest uh of a personal gr
and uh full U
fullment uh building upon moves the the
self Dimension Theory El creation the s
f of interance motiv in fasing
Psychology will begin and optim uh uh
F uh understand the role of in
Psychology needs uh such as Unity
compliment and re uh
winess uh by uh
stying uh these uh fundamental needs
invols are are more likely to experience
a science science of weed and well begin
here will be uh why uh reinforcing their
inst motivation to P manful goals so in
the real of organization Behavior
motivation play uh p uh uh plays a patal
role in a shaping Employee
Engagement uh productively and jobs uh
satisfation the experence th of
motivation
highlights
the important of experience uh and
violence and influence uh choice and E
efforts with the workpl according to
this eth
influence are motivated to exert a for
when they believe that they name of
force will lead to describe performance
outcom and that those outcomes will be
like wued and reward by
organization by understanding the
dynamic of exploration Theory and
lawyers can design
inovations uh structures and Performing
Management systems that lean employs
goals with organ organization
object uh therapy fostering a cure of
motivation and performance uh
extremes
so uh so by Lear invent
psychology motivation also plays a cral
role in shaping uh collection behavor
and social movements also so social uh
inating Theory includes that the ways in
which group membership and uh cult IND
devation can influence individual
motivation uh to contribute the to group
groups goals and uphold shared values by
forcing a senses of belonging and
Collective
effect social uh inal can serve as a
powerful motivation for collection
and
action and action and social challenge
leeding to the formation of choosing
communication and evation groups decided
to perform uh to fing is shared cues and
idles in the context of Education
motivation serves as a key theate of
academic performance leaning engagement
and student achievement the achievement
goal the underscores the importantance
of Master goals and performs schools in
shape
students gold in sham students leaning
string and AIC outcomes while manic
goals are driven by a desire for
learning growth and master of new skills
performance Cod are orientated towards a
achieving uh favorable Comm outcomes and
demonstraing complicated drivable to
others by forcing a classroom inovat
that a prosize mystery orienting
learning and emphasizing the value of
effort and uh pring course can create
student motivation and realizing
therapy preventing a cure of adic
experiences uh and uh and lifelong
learning so uh by understanding the
compliments of motivation for
waral uh persp researchers educations
and leader can de uh de holist strange
to cultivate and sustain
motivation for
forening personal growth real liing and
S success in both personal and
professional remotes so thank you by
listening
this